ABC News has this one President Joe
Biden says he will request more funding
for a new coronavirus vaccine President
Joe Biden said Friday that he's planning
to request more money from Congress to
develop another new coronavirus vaccine
as scientists track new waves and
hospitalizations Rise though not like
before
okay well what does this mean on its own
maybe not so much maybe something we
also have this schools close bring back
mask mandates over the rise of covid-19
cases I think we got another one here
citing Rising covet cases these U.S
Hospital Systems have now reinstated
mask mandates
yeah you know it's it's really worrying
to me that um for the first time in
human history a virus is not uh we've
got seasonal viruses but now we're
dealing with an election seasonal virus
which is particularly worried crazy yeah
but uh as always how does it know how
does it know well it's just you know
it's because as more people start
Gathering to uh to Rally this virus
spreads you know all people are going to
these political rests so it's not only
political rights well right makes sense
if it knows the in-person Voting is
coming And So It prepares but if you're
you know rioting it doesn't mind it's
not affected by that they're all wearing
masks yes that's so true writers we're
wearing masks I mean but literally the
writers were wearing masks they didn't
want to be seen either no they didn't
want to spread the virus Libya would you
say that oh of course as always as
always I will stress uh don't take
medical advice from podcasters and talk
to your doctor about what's right for
you that being said
uh it's kind of hilarious that all of
these different preparations are being
being made and it would seem that
another lock down or heavy mandates are
about to unfold so I'm also not a doctor
I'm just a Jew on the internet but uh
and I can see where the confusion would
come but there's something that that
Biden said uh during that when he was
talking about uh the the new uh vaccine
that they're gonna get funding for a
vaccine that works let me read the quote
yeah let me read the quote quote this is
from ABC News back off YouTube
I signed off this morning on a proposal
we have to present to to the Congress a
request for additional funding for a new
vaccine that is necessary comma that
works what is that implication Mr
President now is not the time to be
sowing any kind of anti-vaccine
conspiracy theories okay
why is noted anti-vaxxer Joe Biden not
trusting the science I don't you know
Korean Pierre is just like do I say that
he mixes up his words sometimes or would
I say he was misquoted like how do we
spin this right now make no mistake that
didn't happen
he said he added that's true gas light
until you win he added that it's
tentatively recommended that everybody
get it once the shots are ready it
doesn't exist we have to pass it before
you can find out what happens when you
inject it like it that's literally no
you don't need to test vaccines I don't
know what you're talking about it hasn't
even been developed yet but you have to
take it yeah because this time it will
work and again this is Joe Joe Biden who
is also not a doctor is
she's a doctor of education but it's not
really a doctor it's called something
else is it yeah
it's not a PhD it's called something
else I'm pretty sure she has her PhD no
no it's not a PhD it's something else
it's not she doesn't even have a
doctorate it's it's an educational
doctorate is called something else
listen whatever she is if she tells me
that the thing that hasn't even been
invented yet I have to take it then I
have to trust her because she does call
herself a doctor well because she did
recommend it for everybody would you did
you figure out what it is she has a
doctor in education but it's not saying
it's not it's not a pH
I'm looking oh it's an ed HD or
something right yeah it is yeah yeah but
they're saying she can still use the
term doctor they're really mainstream
media is really defending her ability
they really want her to be able to use
it I think that's why she got the PHD Dr
Jill Biden just deserves her title what
she has an EDD okay or an at d right
educational doctorate okay so a
doctorate yes that's not a picture sorry
sorry I don't even uh whatever I don't
know what philosophical doctorate is
that what a PhD is yeah yeah that is so
stupid anyway yeah credentialism
she slap slap a title typically Dr
Hannah what were you saying that's me
thank you
medical doctor but he's a philosophical
doctor no I think he's a doctor of
podcasting that's true
announce the creation of Tim Cass
University and the uh uh granting of the
PHD to Libby thank you
and no one ever said my University was
accredited but nobody asked and I
tentatively recommend to everyone enroll
in this because this is a university
that's going to work okay but in all
seriousness it's decentralized here's my
question here's my question to YouTube
this vaccine doesn't exist yet are we
allowed to question it
I can't wait for your course on this the
coming fall term are you allowed to
question a vaccine they have not yet
invented I don't know I guess it's a
Socratic method look at this this is
perfect
[Laughter]
future science yeah but now back to the
politics
do you guys think they're gonna lock
everybody down
I don't and here's why the environment
well let me rephrase that I think there
are some areas some of the the more
Bluer and more uh I guess more
metropolitan areas might have limited
restrictions I don't think we're going
to see the kind of lockdowns we saw
before because that required an
environment of people that this was a
brand new thing that they were horrified
at I remember when I made my first
anti-lock Down video in March of 2020
and I was being attacked by Libertarians
many as many Libertarians who were
saying well we don't know how serious
this is maybe we should you know maybe
we should they're scared wait and see
they were scared people were
legitimately and understandably in the
apocalypse I mean come on everyone was
comparing it to the movie Contagion sure
and the thing is had it been that I
still would have been against lockdowns
because only an idiot would have gone
out outside you wouldn't have needed to
mandate it but it created an environment
where average everyday people were like
you know what let's at least give it a
couple weeks I don't know let's give it
a couple months I don't think that
happens this time I mean we're we're it
covet never went away and everyone's
just like you know what we now know what
it is we know like our relative you know
risk tolerance and so forth we're going
to live our life kind of doing what
we've been saying from all along if you
don't feel well stay home and if you
think you're a high risk tolerance then
adjust accordingly and if you don't then
adjust accordingly I I don't think
lockdowns are going to be something
they're going to be able to do well and
even fauci had some has thrown around
the word endemic right it's harder to
get people to to lock down for something
that they've been living with for
several years and have figured out how
to manage right like I don't really hear
people saying like well you have to test
before you come to my wedding or
whatever anymore I also have this theory
that they actually don't want full-blown
lockdowns because that means that kids
would have to go back to online
schooling and that really drove a surge
in homeschooling right because it
uncovered all these things where parents
were mad because we got to see like
that's like it was when my son was doing
virtual learning that I realized that
they were having a two-day course on uh
what was it white privilege and systemic
racism and I got my voice recorder ready
and I lined it up and I like feel like
we're taking this class together the
whole thing bang for like the two days
of that that's one my son was like Mom
our whole family is racist and I was
like incorrect no no not actually also a
Democrats president and they don't want
massive job losses so I mean there's
that as well I I don't I don't see and
they can't and if they had to pay
everybody to stay home they'd have to
pull money from Ukraine and we already
know that zelinski's asked us and Europe
to fund the next election or they do
like they did in 2020 and 2021 and just
print out like 40 of all the currency
amazing and so where we already have
high inflation in a year or so later now
you're looking at 15 20 official
inflation and probably closer to 25
unofficial you guys I just I don't see
that happening I do they're they're
pushing these Mass mandates and I think
it's a lot of it is like how far can we
push government is a habitual line
stepper it is this constant like how
much can I make people do what I want
them to do but I think they realize that
the lockdowns even with people people as
scared as they were they turned up the
the boiling water a little too hot for
the Frog to tolerate they've kind of
gone back and I think now they're going
to do these like kind of smaller thing
like well can we get a mask mandate but
just in you know the more blue areas is
that going to work how far can we push I
don't see lockdowns happening we were
talking about this before and I said I
think that they'll do guidelines
recommendations recommendations guidance
remember guidance that gives them
ability to roll out universal mail-in
voting and oh that's not happening no
that's happened but they'll have an
excuse now they'll say well we're not
gonna we we can't lock everything down
because the economy you know so we're
going to recommend people quarantine
we're going to recommend masks and we're
going to recommend vaccines and
obviously for those that have decided to
quarantine which is the right thing to
do we're going to send you a mail-in
mail-in vote so then what they do is
they just say we're going to send
everyone a mail-in vote because we're
not going to spy on you and see who's
choosing a quarantine and who's not and
that'll be their justification We're Not
Gonna spine you right now but we will
other times we are spying on you but
we're not going to admit that we're
explaining
yeah they're spying on everybody that's
nice in the in the new update I think it
would be hard to get certain states to
lock down especially Governors that are
ambitious politically having seen
basically desantises rise because of his
stance against the lockdowns yeah I
think you would maybe get a couple blue
Governors who are like this is a morally
correct thing to do but for the most
part they know it's it's essentially a
political death sentence they got to do
something because uh Trump's going Trump
lost I I love the never trumpers and
they're like Trump can't possibly win so
he lost by 42 000 votes in three states
he just needs to win these swing States
that's the key right now the country's
mask it's Georgia Arizona and Wisconsin
is that what I think you talked about
those three even though Michigan I think
it's Wisconsin
Michigan he won Michigan in 2016 but it
was by a slipper yeah and then they got
Whitmer no but uh someone want to look
up what the margins were in 2020 we know
what they were in Georgia
780. right I think in uh in Michigan it
might have been like 20 000 or something
I could be wrong someone look I'll look
it up yeah uh look I think Trump can
recover in any one of these states I
think Trump might could even get a
couple percentage points of of the
popular vote and the reason is
you know you get all these people that
think 2020 was stolen because fraudulent
ballots and double counting and things
like that it's like okay sure fine maybe
whatever prove it uh maybe you're right
I think the real issue was actually
simple everyone was locked in their
house and the mail and votes arrived
it's just a really simple equation lock
everyone inside house mail them ballot
blame Trump then knock on their door and
say can I have that ballot back please
now if there's no lockdown they'll go
knock on the door and let's say the
failure rate here is only seven percent
let's say 93 of the doors they knock on
someone is home
and we'll fill out the belt and give it
back a seven percent drop Trump wins
even seven percent we saw that from the
story about
um Donald Trump and the hunter Biden
laptop story that if uh what what did
they say it was like 17 wasn't it 17 no
it was I would have changed that vote if
they had known about the laptop and that
accounted for they said something like
if seven percent of people did not vote
Democrats or switched for Trump trump
wins I think it was less than seven it
was like a lot less because it was a 42
000 in these a few States
if the Democrats lose
a small fraction of the people who are
locked in their houses they can't win I
don't care what the popular vote is even
if Trump could or couldn't get it the
electoral vote they they're not going to
be able to secure thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time